[Musique]
c'est
à moi
donc nos filles sont excisées quand elles sont
très jeunes et elles sont excisées euh je
veux dire au personnel médical, dans
n'importe quelle situation ou quoi qu'il en soit, peut-être qu'ils sont
médicaux mais le le le le  la
rumeur est médicalisée, ils se déroulent
dans des hôpitaux ou ces
personnels médicaux viennent chez eux et
ils le font à de très jeunes filles, donc
l'hypothèse est que cette très jeune
fille, elle guérira d'abord et pourra
continuer avec elle
[Music]
école donc vous prenez ce que vous faites, c'est
juste que vous obtenez le T des théories et que vous coupez juste
un tout petit
morceau, une des raisons était que si vous étiez
incirconcis, ils pensaient que vous
seriez sexuellement actif et nécessairement et
donc c'est comme quand vous l'êtes  circoncis
comme s'ils réduisaient un peu la libido
ouais, c'était l'une des principales raisons pour lesquelles
je suis heureux que le gouvernement ait interdit les MGF
parce que dans certaines communautés, c'était si
extrême que cela affecterait les femmes
qui accouchent et en tant que sage-femme, je suis tombée
sur un  quelques-uns d'entre
eux en livrent donc certains
parce que euh, cela provoque des coupures effrayantes de
la région génitale et parfois d'autres
pourraient non seulement couper les clitoris mais
couperaient également les petites et les
grandes et efface le canal du bain
maman pourquoi papa pourquoi moi maman pourquoi  moi papa
pourquoi moi mon
peuple [Musique] nos filles ont été formées
aux enseignements de compétences de vie qui
leur sont nécessaires euh pour devenir des
jeunes filles et de futurs
adultes responsables donc aujourd'hui c'est une cérémonie pour leur
coming out elles seront marquées d'avoir
réussi ce droit  de passage euh où
pourquoi traditionnellement elles seraient considérées
comme des grandes filles donc aussi de la même manière
aujourd'hui elles seront aussi considérées comme des grandes
filles mais sans avoir subi la
coupure [Applaudissements] [Musique]
ja